we've been talking about the major
conflicts of interest that are riddling
the Donald Trump transition from
billionaire Manhattan business dude to
President of the United States I told
you about this meeting at his new
Washington DC hotel with diplomats which
led to world diplomats saying of course
we're going to stay at Trump's hotel
when we come here for state business why
would we stay at his competition and
risk upsetting the president we will
stay at his business in order to
ingratiate ourselves with him I told you
about this phone call with the
Argentinian president where reportedly
Trump mentioned wanting help moving
forward a 35-story office building
project that's been stalled for years
although that was denied within a few
days announcements were made that the
project was finally starting to move
forward I told you about Trump's meeting
with Indian business partners sort of
sandwich in and among meetings with
foreign diplomats and presumably
presidential related meetings and lastly
I told you about this idea of Trump
putting his assets in a blind trust and
as I mentioned before giving businesses
you're aware of to your own kids is
neither blind nor a trust the big
announcement yesterday from Donald was
that he will be leaving his great
business in total in order to fully
focus on running the country uh in yet
another one of these cryptic messages
posted to Twitter Donald Trump said
quote I will be holding a major news
conference in New York City with my
children on December 15th to discuss the
fact that i will be leaving my great
business in total in order to fully
focus on running the country in order to
make America great again leaving the
business on paper does nothing to change
whether it's okay for Trump to talk
about his businesses with foreign
leaders or about real estate projects
that are his kids businesses with
diplomats the issue is not the on paper
ownership or whether Trump has a formal
role or title it's the commingling of
business and governance interest in
priorities when he's president of the
u.s. he made this promise during the can
I'm pain to quote hand over control of
the business to his kids and this would
do nothing to reduce the obvious and
arguably unconstitutional conflicts of
interest that have been pointed out by
both Bush and Obama ethics lawyers who
have said in no uncertain terms if this
isn't fixed Trump would be in violation
of the Constitution's emoluments clause
on the day of his swearing-in and we
actually have a quote from norm Eisen
who's the former ethics lawyer for
President Obama who said although it is
of course important that he have no
involvement in Trump business operations
in order to avoid conflicts he must also
exit the ownership of his business
through using a blind trust or
equivalent otherwise he will have a
personal financial interest in his
businesses that will sometimes conflict
with the public interest and constantly
raise questions Trump needs to divest
that is how there would not be a
conflict uh remaining since we know that
having a business is by definition and
interest that could come into conflict
with the interest of the country only by
divesting would he resolved that
possible conflict and by the way a lot
of this would be way clearer to us if
Trump would release the tax returns
which he hasn't done stunning double
standard Pat when you think about the
Clinton Foundation and Hillary Clinton
remember that Donald Trump referred to
the Clinton Foundation as a vast
criminal enterprise with a pay-for-play
scheme there actually are nonprofit laws
in place which prevent the Clintons from
personally benefiting financially from
the foundation here we have a situation
where the Trump foundation was used as a
political slush fund Donald Trump owns
businesses it doesn't matter whether
he's operating them or are or not these
are conflicts of interest and just think
how crazy it is that the only news
conference Trump is scheduled since July
is to talk about something that should
have been a given a long time ago we
don't know what he'll announce on the
15th but if it's I'm leaving the
organization it doesn't resolve any
conflict of interests and Donald Trump
has been brazen enough to say that the
president the United States
can't even have a conflict of interest
right which I mean is true in the sense
that some laws applying to some federal
employees don't pertain to the president
yes but the emoluments clause in the
Constitution when it comes to accepting
gifts from foreign leaders it's very
clear and you just really do it because
it's the right thing to do not because
it's legally required to how are the pro
Constitution uh Republicans saying the
president cannot possibly violate the
Constitution by virtue merely of being
president of the United States this idea
if the president does it it's by
definition not illegal and I was looking
at some comments online and a Reddit
user named magic sonar pointed this out
really well in a post every president in
the last 60 years has released tax
returns and either divested of assets
that could cause conflicts or actually
place them in a blind trust uh every
president has also uh not needed to have
a news conference to explain what they
are going to do with these conflicts of
interest and that if Trump does this
news conference just to say I'm giving
the assets to my kids all he's doing is
saying he's going to keep a campaign
promise which was number one already
made and number two inadequate so this
is all up but that it's incredibly
likely that this will be another one of
these trump smoke and mirrors
manipulations more about optics and PR
then actually solving the problem that
bush and obama ethics lawyers have been
talking about it's amazing that so much
time is going into this because it needs
to because these are outrageous
conflicts of interest